[Music]
welcome everybody great to see so many
people here late in the day I know it's
been a long day for a lot of us hope
hope it's gone well for you guys a very
interesting talk today focused on
machine learning in production and how
to architect for scale so I am a member
of the Solutions Architect team in
Google cloud my role is to basically
help Google cloud customers use machine
learning technology I turn that into
solutions that ultimately get published
on our cloud Google comm site this is a
very very near and dear topic to me I'm
by the way I'm gonna be joined later on
stage by a couple colleagues drew
Houghton and Kevin sy so I'll be
bringing them up later to talk about
some interesting topics related to ml
and production and how you scale it so
let's take a look at the agenda first
we're gonna talk about what we mean by
scale in the context of machine learning
because there are some specific aspects
with respect to scaling that that apply
to machine learning that don't apply to
other domains we're going to give a very
high-level overview of architecture for
machine learning on GCP different ways
that you can do it some bait some
components and services that we that we
would typically employ in a ml
production system we're going to talk
about cloud ml engine one of the key
services that we have on Google cloud
for machine learning in production and
elsewhere we're gonna talk about how did
use kubernetes for ML and that's where
my colleague drew is gonna come up and
give you an overview of that and then
we're gonna focus and drill down on
scaling in the context of training and
prediction so there's a lot of content
to get through here I'm gonna try to
move fast so that we get through all of
it so let's get started so I'd like to
start with this quote by everybody who
has ever tried namely that doing ml and
production is hard and and if you have
tried it you probably aware of this so
let's anyway let's talk about what do we
mean by scale when we say ml production
scaling architecting for scale what do
we mean well there's a basic definition
for scale in architecture in general on
cloud or elsewhere that you know as load
increases we want to maintain
availability in response time I mean
that's kind of a standard definition for
for scalability that that isn't really
specific to ml we want those those
characteristics to remain within
acceptable ranges right so as as the
load increases on predict then we want
to make sure that the latency associated
with each prediction stays reasonably
constant or doesn't fall outside of a
range that would not work for us
but you know and again for for training
machine learning we care about things
like having the time to convergence that
it scales kind of you know in a
reasonable way with the amount of data
that we have right so that's something
that we don't typically have to concern
ourselves with when we're scaling in
other production contexts and then for
prediction we want to make sure that as
the model complexity increases that the
latency associated with each request
also scales appropriately that we don't
hit some you know exponential or some
some wall that where suddenly as our
model gets too complex
our prediction latency falls off the
cliff and it's even more complicated
than that with machine learning because
you have to worry about machines
specific hardware machine learning
specific hardware like GPUs and CPUs
right you know those those introduced
different dynamics into the scaling
process and and furthermore as you know
if you're building machine learning
models we don't just care about
performance you know in training or
production but also about the process of
building machine learning models right
that has to scale - in other words we
know that we're gonna have to run
hundreds maybe thousands of experiments
and we need a system that allows us to
do that at scale in an efficient way so
that's that's also a really important
thing to pay attention to right you know
we need to have a system that allows us
to not just scale when we're in
production but scale while we're
training our model in in the development
environment all right so let's talk
about the architecture landscape for
ml and production as it exists today
it's a rapidly changing environment
right and it's going to be a probably a
little bit of a different story even six
months from now but as it exists today
we have a you know a set of best
practices and standard templates or
architectures that we would use for
deploying ml and production on cloud so
I just want to make the I want to start
by making the point that Google has
achieved a scale in the deployment of
production machine learning that really
probably isn't duplicated anywhere else
at any other company in the world right
so we have proven that it's possible to
deploy machine learning models in
production at the scale in the in on the
order of thousands of models right in
fact that graph shows it doesn't
actually go out to 2018 but we're now
well over 5000 models in production
pipelines that are in production doing
machine learning that are powering a lot
of the services that you see over there
on the on the right
obviously search buddy but drive
translate Gmail Maps YouTube and so on
right so and machine learning is
critical to all of those services and
all of those services are supported by
machine learning pipelines running in
Google's own internal cloud so we
figured out how to do it we had to you
know machine learning is really core to
Google's business and this is one of the
the keys the secrets that we've that
we've developed to solve that scaling
problem internally at Google we
published this paper last year so it's
no secret but we have a common
architecture that we use to build and
deploy our machine learning models at
Google called tf-x
I mean you should take lesson number one
from that is that having a common
architecture that you use to build and
deploy and serve your models is is
critical right if you're going to do it
at scale and so we've realized that for
a long time we built this tf-x common
architecture based on the learnings of
many many years of doing this in
production and the other point that I
want to make about scaling in general
this applies to you know particularly to
Google
cloud is that we're gonna and we're
gonna assume that in this talk that
we're really talking about serverless
architecture right so you're it's gonna
be a lot harder for you to scale if
you're worried about individual servers
for your training cluster or your or
even your your data pre-processing
pipeline and GCP is explicitly designed
to leverage serverless architecture for
all parts of this pipeline so we're
going to assume that we're talking about
server lists that kind of takes a lot of
the stuff off the table when with
respect to scaling but server this
architecture is going to be key for
scaling so this is a high level
architecture diagram of tf-x it was
present in the paper there's actually a
talk in the tensorflow dev summit that
you can go out and find on youtube that
talks about this architecture not all of
this has been open sourced the there are
there are a few components of tf-x that
have been open sourced and we do plan
and we have explicitly announced as such
on open sourcing the entire stack but
it's not all done yet in particular we
have model evaluation invalid validation
TF model analysis was just open source
on the data transformation side there's
TF transform we've open sourced the
serving component as well
TF serving we actually did that last
year so that by the way those components
are the same components that Google uses
in production for our own internal
workloads
you use so if you use these components
you're basically running on the same
code as Google so but for each of these
architectural components that you would
use in a common architecture for machine
learning in production there are GCP
services that correspond to those I'm
not going to go through all of them just
in the interest of time I do want to
point out that yeah so those are all the
services that hexagons for GCP that
correspond to each of those components
like I said I'm not going to go through
the whole thing in detail I do want to
point out again some of the key
components that you would use not tf-x
based right
that services in on GCP that you would
use to solve these problems right so for
training ml Engine Land and G ke are
basically kubernetes with ku flow
sitting on top of it are two of the best
answers we have for that
we're going to talk in more detail about
each of those later for tuning ml engine
offers a high per frame attorneys tuning
service and if you haven't taken
advantage of it you really should it's
one of the key differentiators for
Google and for Google cloud even in the
realm of machine learning in fact I'm
not aware of another cloud service that
offers a tuning service like this you
know this means adjusting all the knobs
on your ML models to optimize their
performance model evaluate evaluation
validation I mentioned T FX model
analysis it's very critical actually so
that you can understand your how your
model is performing across all of your
data sets and if there's a slice of the
data for example that it's not
performing well on it's also critical
for things like explain ability in ml
which I would love to talk about more oh
we won't but you have to be able to
break down different slices of your
input data in order to understand how
your models really performing in
production and then finally as I
mentioned for serving we have TF serving
which again would typically be deployed
on kubernetes on gke and ml engine as
answers to that so let's talk a little
bit more about cloud ml engine cloud ml
engine has been out for a while it's
quite robust now we have a lot of
customers using it for all kinds of
different workloads it's a platform as a
tensor platform as a service for
tensorflow but as you know not just
tensorflow
anymore so you can run XG boost or
scikit-learn on cloud ml engine and
again it basically serves as on-demand
infrastructure for machine learning so
you can set up clusters to do your
training jobs you can once you've
trained your model then you can take
that same model and deploy it as a cloud
endpoint as a rest endpoint so you can
seamlessly transition from training to
prediction it offers some built in model
version management and then basically
you're still just using
tensorflow so you could take that model
there's nothing locking you in you can
take that model and download it and run
it elsewhere on premise you know even on
another cloud so for our purposes here
for scalability the the pros of ml
engine are that it's very easy to scale
up in terms of asking for more capacity
from our workers you just basically
specify that in your training job and
and it's also nice that the serving
capability is automatic there's been
some recent improvements in things like
startup latency and in other aspects of
serving we're just about to announce
increased capability to use GPUs for
cloud ml engine so it's got a number of
advantages the cons I would say are
associated with you know using
distributed tensorflow which is just not
easy no matter how you slice it again
we're working on the tensorflow team to
make that easier but it still got some
gotchas associated with it we're going
to talk a bit more about that later and
how you can navigate that there are some
limited limitations
you know like limited machine types
which again we're working on resolving
so again there's there's some you know
some limitations in the service that
make it not ideal for for some cases but
it's still quite a very powerful service
you know with with serving for example
again ml engine in terms of scale
scalability you don't you don't you're
not in charge of provisioning the number
of machines there are some knobs and
tweet you know parameters that you can
tweak but essentially it scales
according to your load which is great
all right for section on kubernetes for
machine learning I'm gonna bring up my
colleague drew Houghton on the CEM L
specialist team and have him tell you a
bit about that awesome Thank You Luc Mon
so for this section we're gonna talk
about the best of two worlds that I I
work with customers quite a lot on one
is kubernetes and one is machine
learning and see look at how kubernetes
can help solve some of the problems
totally an open source and across
multiple clouds so MLM production for
those of us that have tried or have done
MLM production we know that we care
about these three things composability
portability and scalability and let's
talk about each of those
first is composability when you solve an
ml problem on your laptop eye it's easy
to solve some problems may be on Cagle
in on your laptop small to medium data
set with what I call it's kind of what I
call toy machine learning you solve the
problem maybe you won the competition
but that's not the same as taking your
solution scaling it and making it
worthwhile and and sort of frankly you
know worth the money and the effort for
the enterprise there's a lot of things
that come after that
not just the tuning and building the
model but deploying it at scale
refreshing your model every week day 15
minutes if you have cold start problems
a B testing model evaluation and serving
at scale right the reality is that to do
each of these different portions of the
pipeline there's different systems we
have data ingestion so you know where is
the data coming from is it real-time is
it streaming is it from a variety of
different systems who's putting it all
together in a data Lake we have our data
analysis and validation so this is
exploring the data understand
understanding what we can actually model
or glean from the data then we actually
have the model building itself the
training the hyper parameter tuning and
lastly the serving serving at scale
keeping the model fresh now in practice
these are often different people if not
different entire teams doing this at
scale in production right so there's
different very different skill sets very
different systems and it makes sense
right these are different very different
problems one of the promises of ml is
that we sort of unify all of the we
unify a lot of our data we apply an
algorithm to a business problem we do it
in real time now this is great but when
you have lots of teams involve lots of
systems involved it can become more
difficult to scale every time you deploy
a model do you have to get every team
involved so we care about composability
essentially reusing different pieces
from each stage with sort of limited
engagement or friction each time I want
to build a model for example building a
model that can be used by a software
engineer in the future on similar data
without having to go back to that ml
searcher now some of us also care a lot
about portability so just show a show of
hands in the room who's using kubernetes
or has explored with kubernetes a lot of
hands right this that's awesome to see
and and these days definitely the best
place to run containers at scale one of
the great things about kubernetes is you
get a similar that the the way we've
abstracted the compute you can take your
application and move it very easily from
your laptop to a on premise cluster to
one of various cloud providers and this
is something very important to lots and
lots of organizations we hear this again
and again also we have great primitives
in kubernetes with dealing with things
like this so Joe bethe one of the
cofounders of kubernetes says the way I
think about it every difference between
devastation production will eventually
result in an outage and it's very easy
in kubernetes at least easier than and a
lot of other systems of treating things
like dev staging and Pradas sort of
first-class citizens that the app
understands and helps to limit the
problems you're gonna face so let's talk
about portability with machine learning
now because machine learning is such a
compute and performance intensive
application we actually care a lot about
all the different pieces of our our
system all the way down to the hardware
but it's not just the hardware it's up
to the drivers anyone had problems
installing drivers and and takes a long
time before you can actually start
working on your problem can be quite um
nightmare the frameworks they change
very quickly you know this is a very
rapidly moving space there's a lot of
effort that goes into building the stack
on a laptop getting data training
getting a model working you're super
lucky that converges right away but
again this is great for solving a toy ml
problem what happens if I want a skill
or I want to deploy this in production
now I'm dealing with different
environments right maybe I have a
training rig in the back you know
cooling the office maybe I'm using an
on-prem cluster we have existing
significant GPU or CPU investments maybe
this isn't a cloud provider
we're multiplying the complexity of
keeping these environments in sync it
was already hard enough to get the
laptop up and running that environment
perfect for what we wanted to do it gets
even more complex so pop quiz what's
really good at composability Portability
and scalability kubernetes you got it
containers and kubernetes and guess what
Google runs all of our machine learning
on containers and essentially you know
Borg but the the influence behind
kubernetes so this can be done and we
have some great news kubernetes today
has a lot of great primitives and and
support for machine learning workloads
we support accelerators and it very easy
to use extensible manner so GPUs are in
beta CPUs are an alpha with just one
line of in your community's manifest you
can request GPUs for your pods it's
really easy to schedule lots of GPUs and
bring lots of horsepower to your
workloads the existing controllers and
kubernetes also simplify a lot of the
DevOps challenges we face now let's
let's remember the reason we want to use
kubernetes here is we get lots of wins
from the infrastructure standpoint from
the repeatability standpoint and from
the DevOps standpoint we want to apply
those wins to our machine learning
workloads some of the ways that does
this is kubernetes jobs so when i create
a kubernetes job maybe this is a
training job kubernetes will then go
create a pod or multiple pods to try and
complete that job if a node fails let's
say I'm using preemptable nodes or
preemptable GPUs it'll take that job
it'll schedule it somewhere else for me
if I'm using say the tensorflow
estimator api i'm checkpointing
regularly my job is all of a sudden
stateless in a way you know kubernetes
will recreate the pod it'll keep
training somewhere else on the data
center we also have kubernetes
deployments which are great for serving
so you tell kubernetes
what your deployment looks like where
the container is or where the model is
how fast you want to scale it and it
does all the rest for you as your load
increases kubernetes will create more
pods on your
behalf it also scales at this point I
think kubernetes is will scale up to
5,000 nodes and that's increasing quite
rapidly and we also have container base
images for ML workloads so you don't and
in some cases you don't actually have to
build your own containers you can use an
off-the-shelf tensorflow
CPU container and then there's a GPU
container and if you're comfortable with
code control you can actually just load
your code up at runtime there's benefits
to building your own containers but you
don't even need to to get started using
kübra hub and kubernetes for ml so this
is great we have the the right
primitives we have the right tools that
the kubernetes supports what a lot of
things I just talked about if you're a
data scientist or machine learning
researcher might not be as familiar to
you right maybe you feel like I need to
learn about containers container
building endpoints for serving and
persistent volume scaling all these
things before I can be really effective
with machine learning on kubernetes you
know we see the promise here we like
that we can get a consistent environment
or we can get a similar environment on
Prem to the cloud but there's a lot of
other things we still have to build so
the good news is we have an answer and
that is cube flow so cube flow is an
open source project whose goal is to
make it easy for everyone to learn
deploy and manage portable distributed
machine learning on kubernetes so
basically to get all those
infrastructure kubernetes wins but make
it really easy for those that aren't
kubernetes experts and this is a trend
we're seeing more and more in the
kubernetes world is higher level
frameworks that make it really easy to
solve a particular problem so what does
coop Lowell get us gets us composability
we have a variety of existing popular
open-source tools I'll dive into those
in a little bit we use case on it for
packaging and easily setting up your
environment so all of a sudden dev
staging production and laptop are all
first-class citizens and with just a
couple commands you can deploy to each
of them the same exact code
it's very portable cue flow is totally
open source using totally open source
components and a lot of those components
are cloud native kubernetes native
components I'll talk about those in just
a second what's great is that we're let
the huge community that's that's built
up around kubernetes is solving your
problems so you can focus your
deployment problems so you can focus on
the actual machine learning problem and
lastly it's scalable right tensorflow
already supports CPU GPU TPU distributed
kubernetes skills like crazy we can use
that power to handle our serving
workloads and our training workloads so
what does this look like and how does
this solve this whole mess well for
those of you that know kubernetes will
actually solve a lot of it for you
that's why we were looking at kubernetes
as a solution right so I'll kind of go
back and forth kubernetes will give you
a pretty consistent API up to the run
time so I don't have to worry about this
anymore I have I've abstracted my
compute to be a really nice level and I
don't have to I don't have to worry
about keeping it in sync now that said
you're still having to worry
traditionally about the framework what
my storage is maybe drivers cube flow
with just a couple commands can be
installed on mini cube on your laptop
mini cube is a a local mini kubernetes
cluster running in a VM but you get the
same API as if on your laptop as if you
were in a five thousand two cluster with
thousands of GPUs a couple commands you
install cube flow on your laptop on your
on-premise existing cluster on various
cloud clusters and now you have a
consistent ml ready environment across
all your wherever you do compute so
what's included in cube flow so we
actually just release version point two
so we're we are earlier in the days of
queue flow but this is developing very
rapidly because customers do want a
solution that spans across clouds for
some customers being totally open source
is very important running in multiple
clouds on an on-prem is very important
same reasons we've seen the popularity
with kubernetes in general what's
included today is Jupiter hub for
collaborative
interactive training a tensorflow
training controller so now you don't
have to tell kubernetes what a
tensorflow training job looks like or
how did you do distributed tensorflow
you just tell it hey here's my code run
it distributed fairly very similar to
how you would do is cloud a mail engine
same thing with serving you don't have
to tell kubernetes what intensive flow
serving is you just say here's my model
go serve it and auto scale it we have
our go for workflows so creating a
consistent pipeline from pre-processing
to training hyper parameter tuning and
validation seldom core for complex
inference and non TF models I want to
stress that this is not just for tensor
flow we have PI torch and alpha you we
have definitely have people running
psych it actually boost in Selden core
you can run whatever frameworks you want
also in point two we release hyper
parameter tuning and ambassador for
reverse proxies so this is a very
rapidly moving project all right and
then for our next section I'm gonna
invite Kevin up or for scaling training
yeah so I'm gonna have Kevin come up now
and talk about scaling training is
particularly challenging distributed
training on GPUs thanks Kevin thanks
alabang okay what are very common
questions that we get from the community
is when we I had one gi1 sheep you and I
just upgraded my VM to four GPUs but
training is just too slow with what's
going on right if you take a step back
and try to think about what you're doing
with intent within tensorflow you're
creating a graph and then you're
executing the graph right and by default
if you don't specify where your graph
goes and tends flow sees one or more
GPUs it'll throw the operations in GPU
zero right so there's a really nice tool
from Nvidia called Mbita SMI if you run
that during training you'll be able to
see how busy your GPUs are if you run it
on multiple GPUs and you see something
like this all right that probably means
that you know you created a graph that
only had busyness in GPU zero right so
that's actually the expected behavior if
you don't specify
paralyzation over multiple GPUs so let's
take a look at a very simple model right
and we use this to describe what we're
trying to do in paralyzation one of the
ways to paralyze across multiple GPUs is
called data parallelism and basically
what you're doing is you are replicating
your entire model across two or more
GPUs and then you go ahead and divide up
the data coming in into you know smaller
batches so let's say for example if your
batch size is 256 and you split it over
to GPUs you have 128 go to the GPU 0 128
go to GPU 1 right so that's pretty
straightforward the other way of
paralyzing is called model parallelism
and typically you you wouldn't use this
unless you get to a point where your
model is really big or you're running
out of memory and GPUs and so forth
right and it's actually also possible to
put model parallelism and data
parallelism together now one of the
challenges when we do when we're
splitting data into two or more GPUs
right is at the end you're gonna end up
with multiple result sets right so if
you think about the predictions you
start it with 256 128 goes to one side
and 120 goes to the other side the
prediction is actually pretty
straightforward you just concatenate
that right but gradients a little bit
more complex so what do you what we
normally do with gradients coming from
the two GPUs will go ahead and average
that all right and one of the things
that we also found at Google is to do
best to have the best chance of
convergence what we want to do is we
want to do synchronous replication right
meaning that we want to be able to after
each batch you want to calculate the
gradient apply the gradient update the
parameters and then go to the next batch
right that's the best performance but
that also means that the gradient
averaging becomes a blocking process so
it's very important that we have a very
fast method of applying the gradients
right so one of the ways that we could
do that is just go ahead and use a CPU
as the
consolidation mechanism so after each
batch the GPUs will each copy the
gradients to the CPU and the CPU will go
ahead and average it out make the update
step and redistribute the gradients the
sorry the parameters back across all the
GPUs and that's one way to do it but as
you can really kind of see over here if
we increase the number of GPUs you're
gonna increase number of copies that you
have to average out and then that
becomes a bottleneck right so a more
performant way of doing it is to use an
all reduce type of mechanism to go ahead
and do the distribution right the other
advantage of doing an all reduced type
mechanism is that you could take
advantage of the very fast and be link
right whereas like if you're going to
let the CPU do the consolidation you
have to go through PCIe so when it comes
to machine learning PCIe is slow alright
just remember that all right PCI is
actually really slow okay so at the if
you take a step back here are the kind
of the options right if you were to go
ahead and choose a distribution strategy
or distribution distribution method
today here are kind of like the the high
level what you can choose from so if you
have a single server it's not too hard a
lot of you know built-in capabilities
within tons flow and caris that's
available so ever since 1.5 we have
replicate model FN and within Charis
Charis actually had had their multi-gpu
model strategy even before tensorflow
did but in both cases you have to
remember that these are CPU bound right
meaning that it uses they use the CPU as
a consolidation strategy as whereas in
test 1.8 we introduced mirrored strategy
which is part of a larger family called
distribution strategy and mirrored
strategy currently is single server but
multiple GPUs and it uses the all
reduced type of mechanism as well now if
one server is not good enough there are
also options for multiple servers right
and so you you might have heard they
talk about TPU so there's TPU is one of
the options who go ahead and go very
parallel the other option there's an
open-source project called horror Vlad
put together by a couple of really smart
engineers at goober so that gives you
the ability to scale over multiple
servers with multiple GPUs as well and
they should be strategy again is it's
going to be offered as a multi multi
server option as well
now one mention is if you look at the
older tends to flow documentation
there's a mention of parameter server
and workers because this method is not
has not really is is not as effective in
coming to convergence compared to the
other methods what we would recommend is
that's probably not the first solution
that you should look at ok so just want
to spend a little time on distribution
strategy so what we realized is a lot of
our a lot of users already have a lot of
code that's written and we want to be
able to make it so that you can kind of
shoehorn this capability into your code
without a lot of changes so what we've
done is we have put this capability into
run config so you create you specify a
distribution strategy in this case merge
strategy and you would go ahead and put
that as one of the parameters within run
config and you create the estimator that
way right and if you're using Kerris we
also support the model to estimator
conversion and within there you'll go
ahead and specify run config as well
thank you Kevin thank you so so we heard
a lot of really interesting information
about how to scale using kubernetes as a
common architecture and coop flow and we
also heard some really interesting
information about distributing over
multiple GPUs and again we will as a
company always continue to support and
encourage people to leverage GPUs on our
Google cloud environment we also as you
know provide our own hardware
acceleration option TP use and someone
to talk just a little bit about that as
well so TP use are now at version one
and two both of those have been deployed
in Google Cloud
well TPU version one was actually
deployed internally in Google's
infrastructure on board TPU version two
has been made available to our customers
at Google cloud and today we announced
TPU version three acts I think we
announced that at i/o but anyway we're
continuing on developing and improving
that architecture and you should expect
TPU 3.0 to be launched sometime later
this year in cloud and the way we make
this available to our customers on cloud
is something called cloud TPU it's
essentially a service that wraps around
TPU resources that live in a pod and
make it easy for you to you know do your
training jobs that using GPUs this is a
quick example of sort of what that looks
like in code essentially as Kevin
mentioned you know there's you know just
as simple as basically using a TPU
estimator instead of a regular estimator
and then there's some other things you
have to do to connect to a cloud TPU but
it's it's designed to be relatively
simple to do and we do have a lot of
customers now taking advantage of GPUs
so for certain kinds of workloads it can
be quite effective again this is an
example of another code change that one
could use in order to take advantage of
TPU so just but using a TPU version of
the optimizer
again it's not for every problem right
you need to have enough data and and
enough need for scale in order to
justify the work that you that you do in
order to customize for TPU so again
situations where you got very large
models with very large batch sizes the
models need to be able to run on TPU so
not all models currently do just worth
pointing out we will get there
eventually but even as of today there
are certain operations that would not be
supported so you may have a model that
just won't run on TPU and you don't want
to use cloud TPU for very you know small
models or models with lots of branches
or again that don't that use operations
that aren't supported we're going to
talk a little bit about input pipeline
performance that's another key aspect of
training of scaling with respect to
training so the first point I want to
make is that if you're not using the TF
data API you should be alright this is
as of about a year ago or so basically
our recommended architecture for
building data pipelines in tensorflow
again there are older methods out there
using input queues and so on but we
really strongly recommend that you use
this API for your to specify your data
pipelines but just using this API by
itself doesn't necessarily doesn't
necessarily get you there right so this
is an example of a res net 50 data set
api coded you know simply I mean there's
nothing wrong with the way this is coded
but you get through this about 150
images per second and and really you
should be able to expect for this image
net problem you know something over a
thousand images per second so what what
is the issue with this code and what can
we do to optimize it well again I the
way when you're approaching the
optimization of input pipelines we
suggest that you think is like ETL
basically you know separate the process
of extracting the data from the storage
transforming that data to prepare it for
train
which typically has to happen and then
loading that data into the accelerator
think of those in distinct phases
because different parts of the
infrastructure are going to be dedicated
to that and so if you can segment those
processes such that those different
pieces of infrastructure are allowed to
operate in parallel then you're going to
get much better throughput so here's an
example where the the operations are
serialized just at a very high level you
know with the time going forward and the
extract transform and load and then
train steps are all synchronous with
each other here and of course you would
see that the various components of the
system are going to be idle at any given
point in that cycle right your CPU is
idle if your CPU is doing the data
transformation its idle while it's
waiting for the next data set to come
through and similarly if you're using
hardware acceleration in this kind of
scheme you're gonna see low GPU
acceleration right that's when you run
that nvidia SMI tool and you see
something like 25 or 40 percent
utilization it's often because of input
pipelining issues so this is what you
want to see instead where the processes
of extraction transformation and loading
are all parallelized sufficiently such
that your training infrastructure your
GPUs or your your custom hardware is the
utilization is maximized so again we
don't have time here to talk about all
of the tricks of the trade that you use
to do this but just let us let let's
note here that the data set API is
really designed to parallel lies in the
same way that we just discussed
so again if you parallel eyes that
mapping operation that's expressed here
across multiple cores just by adding a
parameter to the function call that that
just that's enough to achieve
parallelization there similarly and that
by itself gets you from 150 images per
second to 600 right but there's more you
can do so you can also paralyze the
reading essentially the extract step and
you can paralyze the the prefetch step
that basically allows the data set
to be queued up so you can feed it
faster into the GPU and and with those
two changes just at the same code again
it's basically the same pipeline just
with some extra parallelization
primitives or parameters added to it we
get to over 1750 images per second so
just the point to make here is that it's
very critical to tune your input
pipelines and that can make a huge huge
difference in the way that your training
process scales so we're not going to
talk about scaling prediction and this
is a number of interesting topics here
we're going to talk about how you
optimize your model there's a tool
within tensorflow that's been around for
a while that not probably widely
appreciated called graph transform tool
that we encourage you to make use of to
optimize your models for prediction we
talked a little bit about quantization
and what that is why you would care
about that what you'd use that for
tensorflow light which is a new
framework that's specifically targeted
to make models run fast on mobile
actually it's a framework for
quantization on mobile specifically
we're going to talk about tensor RT
which is a great framework from our
partners at Nvidia that makes it really
fast to to serve models that leverage
some of the capabilities of
the Nvidia hardware and then finally I'm
going to touch on some serving
optimizations that you make the TF
serving to make serving process go
faster so what does graph transform tool
well it'sit's actually present in the
tensorflow codebase it has been for
since I think pre 1.0 and has a number
of operations that are very useful when
you're optimizing your graph for serving
so one of the things that you want to do
typically the serving graph does have
there's some components in the training
graph that aren't necessary for the
serving graph and GTT tool allows you to
strip those unknown unneeded nodes out
of your graph just to make it more
efficient make it a lighter footprint
and and faster for serving again it will
do graph optimization so it'll remove
you know nodes that aren't doing
anything the identity nodes there's
various other nodes that are typically
included in the graph
that are needed for training that aren't
needed for predict if you use batch
normalization which is another topic
that I'd love to have spent some time on
if you're not using batch normalization
and you're training a deep neural
network you're not doing it right you're
not following the best practice you need
to use batch normalization let's just
leave it at that there's some
information out there that you can go
find till you incorporate that it's
pretty easy to do in tensor flow you
will find anywhere from twenty to
sometimes more percent uplift in both
training accuracy and speed to
convergence just by using batch
normalization it's a best practice
there's no researcher in in deep
learning that's not using it so it does
some pre calculation that that makes
batch normalization go faster so that's
the another capability of the graph
transform tool and several other useful
transforms including the ability to
Qantas quantize your graph so what does
quantization well it turns out that
weights thirty two-bit weights are quite
useful for training but for serving we
can often get away with much lower
precision like even down to eight bit
weights actually there are folks out
there doing one bit weights believe it
or not but certainly without losing a
lot of accuracy but but achieving a huge
speed-up in serving performance you can
go from thirty two-bit weights tape add
weights this is very common practice
particularly again when you're deploying
on smaller devices like mobile devices
or devices on the edge it's even more
important because model size really
matters but so you get a big uplift in
both speed and not you know sometimes a
little bit of trade-off in accuracy but
typically not that much if you do this
correctly
tensorflow has built-in support for
quantization so how does this work well
essentially during your training process
you're computing them basically the
minimum of maximum value of these
parameters say weights you're storing
you're storing that as metadata along
with the weight and that allows you
basically to scale the weight from
wherever it's occupies in its range down
to this 8-bit range and then that so you
you don't
just store the way you store a minimum
and maximum value and then you'd so it
makes the graph a little bit more
complicated but you know it's much much
faster to do these things with 8-bit
values that it is with there's no loss
in performance you get a little bit
extra model complexity but you get a big
increase in performance so it's it's
relatively straightforward to do this
again again using the graph transform
tool there's actually other another tool
in the tensor flow code base that is can
be used for quantization called
quantized graph I believe we recommend
that you use this tool frankly I mean
they're both roughly comparable but
graph transform tool allows you to
incorporate several of the other
transforms that are gonna that are going
to be useful when you're doing this to a
model prior to serving tensor flow light
is worth mentioning here it was this was
announced at the recent tensorflow dev
summit and it's a framework built into
tensor flow that basically does this
quantization process for specified for
mobile devices or customized for mobile
devices so this just shows you a graph
of the relative gain in performance
between the tensor flow model and an a
tensor for light quantized model you
know running on a mobile device and I
would encourage you if you're interested
in you know running ml on mobile to
check out this talk on the tensor flow
dev summit it's available in YouTube and
goes into much more detail about tensor
for the light finally like to talk about
tensor RT so our great partners at
Nvidia have basically been working on
this problem themselves how do we
optimize inference given a model and
they've also built some quantization
capabilities into the hardware so the V
100 chip for example includes what are
what are called tensor cores which are
essentially custom hardware components
or chip components that are optimized to
do to execute inference on these
quantized values and tensor RT is a
library that they provide that has been
that they've worked with the tensor flow
team to integrate directly into tensor
flow and so it
it's relatively straightforward and you
can get really really good performance
boosts it's particularly on the chips
like the v100 that have specialized
hardware just to support this so if
you're again you're deploying inference
on V 100's you've got to use tensor RT
or else you're you're you're giving up
you know something could be on the order
of 10 X maybe 20 X factors for
performance finally I just want to talk
a little bit about some optimizations
that you can do to tensorflow serving
and then I think we'll have maybe two
minutes or so left for questions I'm
amazed I know that we got it through all
this if we don't have time if there are
more questions than we have time for
here than mics myself and Drew and Kevin
are gonna be out in the hallway
afterwards so we're fine with you guys
approaching us and we'll answer as many
questions that we can out there all
right so let's talk about optimizing TF
serving well there's really one thing
you have to care about when you're
optimizing TF serving for scale and and
it's really important if you're gonna do
TF serving on GPUs you won't actually
get the benefit of the GPU acceleration
unless you do this which is to optimize
the batching so basically you know this
means instead of feeding a single tray a
predict example through your TF serving
pipeline you batch them together in in
bunches and you and you execute those
all in parallel through the pipeline and
there is some tuning of this process
there's a batching guide tensorflow
serving batching guide that's in the
source for TF serving and I would
encourage you if your using TF serving
at all that you pick that you read this
and pay attention to it because it can
make a big difference in in the way that
your TF serving pipeline performs well
that is it thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]